Sam ammok Amick Sam will you clear that
up for me dan no worries it's Amick as
my uncle Johnny used to say it's long a
Amick is how we do it
oh yeah because then if you were a
McHugh dis be Samak well yeah it does it
gets tricky and then if you try to stand
together its sanic you know you got to
have okay the sharp left turn all right
thank you brother
I Sam that's it that's all I wanted to
ask you about so thanks for joining us
did you break the story about LeBron
James breaking his hand I did yeah I
mean it was it was one of the more
memorable postgame scenes with that
obviously playing a big part you know
and then we were scrambling figuring out
where the the Warriors were gonna be
celebrating and checking out that scene
and then word started to spread that
LeBron was dealing with something what's
fascinating about the whole thing for me
is just that I don't think the general
kind of the average fan was cognizant of
the timeline when it comes to when the
news got out in in relation to when
LeBron decided to put a soft cast on his
hand and so it was the whole thing was
quite it was a trip I mean it's I think
a tough look for LeBron I think he ends
up looking like he's trying to provide
cover for himself but but yes to answer
your question that was the case and
Golden State it came out after the
finals that they were aware that he had
done so you know he had done something
to his hand is that correct I don't know
I mean if that's been reported
that wouldn't surprise me especially
since on the Cavs side you know what I
learned after the fact was that it was
pretty surprising that it hadn't come
out earlier because everybody on the
team knew you know I mean I had and this
is a weird thing I don't typically do as
far as like sharing where you first
found out about stuff but I thought it
was fair to LeBrons camp dude and I have
our you know shared the fact that like
it did not originate from his people
this was not a case of okay the second
the buzzer sounded his people running
around saying hey guess what this wasn't
the real LeBron
you know that's just not how it happened
but I do think it was fairly widely
known in the locker-room circles was it
broken or badly sprained so I mean it's
described to me as a deep bone contusion
that you know I mean the the non doctors
in the group that I who I spoke with
they a little bit like LeBron where they
they essentially say it was basically
broken you know but that's that's
obviously a pretty non scientific way of
looking at it yeah I know the first MRI
the swelling was so bad that they had to
take a second one they couldn't get a
clear look at the damage and then and
this is you know I'm leaning on
colleague and friend Brian Wynn horse of
ESPN I heard on his podcast yesterday he
had described it that it was a small
break I had not been told that I'm sure
Brian has that so I mean it's you know
that's where the lack of a medical
degree hurts guys like Brian and I but
but it was a pretty serious injury that
I do think affected this play I don't
think it was going to turn the series
but you could tell that he played a
little bit differently in the final
three games
what about showing up with a soft cast
on their postgame post finals press
conference a strange move you know I
mean it's even the judging by the
reaction that I got to the column I
wrote the day after the finals you know
it felt like it was 2010 all over again
when it comes to kind of the LeBron hate
and people not reacting well to the
optics in that decision that he made to
put this out cast on you know again the
way it was told to me is that he's
headed to the postgame podium his people
tell him hey by the way it got out
people know you punched the whiteboard
you hurt your hand
yada yada and so then he at that point
makes a decision that as well and that's
out what do I care so he puts his sock
cast on I just I thought not only you
know I don't know how that's helping him
in that moment and it just seems like a
prop to you know I think that's how the
fans took it anyway that a prop to you
know make it apparent that you were
dealing
something and then when the cameramen
started firing away and taking pictures
of it and he had kind of made that joke
about a you guys or you guys are digging
this thing aren't you no or something
along those lines I mean you know what
the Warriors reaction is gonna be you
know what the the fans who have never
completely bought in on LeBron you know
what their reactions gonna be I thought
it was for his purposes
you know just unnecessary because it
ended up bringing a lot of scrutiny how
does it not happen that he goes to the
Lakers he doesn't get help I mean that's
what's I've been texting with people
about that this morning that's what's so
interesting about these next couple of
weeks is that that you have the two
parts of this question in terms of where
he's going to go you have market and
organization that's in one category and
then you have health and if you just if
this was a Power Rankings on market and
organization right now I feel like it's
the Lakers by a long shot and that's
where all the buzz is that's where it
seems that he has a really strong
interest in landing there but I
guarantee he's not going to land there
if he doesn't have a roster that he
looked at and says you know the Warriors
are gonna sweep me again when I see him
in the playoffs I mean why would you
project yourself to that and not even
have the silver lining like he has in
the east of still getting to the finals
and having this incredible streak that
he's had so this is where all the other
names come into play what's Paul George
is doing what's Chris Paul doing guys
are that nature he's got to get help so
I don't know what that looks like yet
Paul George has to end up there I would
think if he doesn't get Paul George then
now what happens first though because
does Paul George wait for LeBron is
LeBron waiting for Paul George what's
Chris Paul is he waiting to get a
five-year deal in Houston and if he
doesn't then he's more likely to
relocate back to Los Angeles how does it
Domino's fall here Sam
so then for the last one the Chris Paul
one I think you know you're hitting the
nail on the head if I mean if Chris
isn't getting five in Houston he's
probably not going to be a happy camper
because by all accounts the fact that
the Clippers didn't put five on the
table a year ago is what prompted the
move to Houston in the first place
mm-hmm but that's where it gets tricky
because there's pity on folks who say
all right but if LeBron is gonna wind up
in Houston with Chris then it'll
probably take some sort of pay cut on
Chris's behalf which people don't know
how to reconcile that with with the
whole backstory like that's you didn't
go there for a pay cut maybe it changes
when it's your best friends that's
possible we'll see the other Domino's
you know and again smoke it's the lying
season when it comes to the draft and
free agency and so we have to chip
through all this stuff but like you know
the latest smoke on the Paul George
front is it's a very reasonable chance
that he winds up going back to OKC and
so I feel like his people him they're
good enough at their jobs that they
they've got to already have a decent
sense of what LeBron is thinking and so
I think that you know if this is where
Paul's head and heart is at and if he
does end up going back to OKC and the
Dominos starts with him and then LeBron
has to respond to that unless you know
then I guess the outlier would be if
LeBron has some incredible scenario up
his sleeve that he can't actually pitch
to these guys until you know late June
and that changes the way they look at
things then who knows what happens from
there but a lot of moving parts yeah I
wondered if he would just stay one more
year in Cleveland and figure out what's
happening
with the Lakers and you know I had
people say that that's very unlikely and
I went well I I mean why not you you
still have a roster who got you to the
finals you know granted Boston's gonna
be better Philadelphia a year you know
you're more seasoning what what did the
chances LeBron just goes you know what
LA it's not it's not right it's not what
I want now again this whole thing is so
compelling to me it's because I can
definitely see that from a pragmatic
standpoint that would be the cautious
play you know you
in the finals you know what you can
accomplish with this group and who knows
that they can trade that number eight
pick for somebody you know some
rumblings about CJ McCollum somebody
like that coming to help LeBron and
convince him to stay we all know you
don't love the owner and we get that but
you know it's kind of like the you know
the devil you know being better than the
one you don't and if you don't have
clarity on these other situations you
can go ahead and wait a year the part of
me that pushes back against that idea as
far as him maybe just opting in and
staying one more year in Cleveland and
just the mood of the moment I mean
having covered the finals and been
around that organization of those people
it just it feels like like it's over
maybe I'm wrong you know who knows again
once he goes home and talks to his
family and they're comfortable and the
kids are doing well and we all know
brownies coming up as a big time
basketball prospect so but in the moment
in the finals and this is you know even
me leaning on other media members who
are on a team every single day I
couldn't run into anybody who felt like
you know LeBron was coming back
what about Golden State's roster next
year super interesting it's all around
the edges but I mean that's but it but
the edges are really important like
that's what they learned in this playoff
run right so if you go back a couple
years before Kevin Durant gets there I
think one thing that we forget is how
just from 1 to 15 they had that roster
on lockdown
the second unit was incredible
defensively you know every guy seemed to
fit perfectly and then you know when you
have a chance of the transcendent player
like Kevin you do it and so you elevated
the core to maybe an unprecedented level
but in the course of the past two years
they've lost grip a little bit on the
others as you know Shaq likes to call
and and I think that's their lesson
learned from this year now it's pretty
nice when you're learning lessons the
hard way while also holding onto the
trophy like they are but I mean the Nick
Young JaVale McGee and all the way down
the line you know
like Nick Young is probably the poster
boy of you had some okay moments late
and it's fun to watch him get a chip
because none of us thought he ever would
but you know next year with that
mid-level exception money that they're
gonna have again I think the focus will
be on guys who play both end to the
floor
you know guys who bring it more
consistently I just don't think they're
going to be as loose with some of the
role player acquisitions great stuff Sam
we appreciate it have a great summer and
we'll check in with you again Sam amick
USA Today NBA insider for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]